bienvenue dans l'afrique honnête sur rt
france le sommet afrique france se
déroule le 8 octobre à montpellier pour
l'occasion un nouveau format exit lé
chef d'état africain tapis rouge à la
société civile aux entrepreneurs à la
jeunesse au monde scientifique de la
culture et du sport l'objectif c'est de
renouveler la relation à afrique-france
l'occasion de se pencher justement sur
les initiatives franco africaine et nous
sommes avec karim ci qui est le
promoteur de la transformation digitale
en afrique fondateur de joe cole à deux
ex président de digital africa
l'initiative d'emmanuel macron ex membre
aussi du conseil présidentiel africain
vous êtes maintenant aussi partenaire de
0,1 talent africa qui soutient des
millions de talent numérique en afrique
bonjour karine si merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans l'afrique collecte
bonjour saint-quentin alors d'abord
votre regard sur ce sommet de
montpellier exit je disais les chefs
d'état africains c'est peut-être un peu
poussif comme expression existe parce
que c'est vrai que bagnols mac on les a
quand même convié avant l'été pour un
grand sommet en grande pompe un sommet
sur le financement quelle est votre
lecture de ce calendrier je pense qu'il
ya eu il y avait le sommet initial qui
était prévu la crise qu vide est passée
par là et ce qu'on nous a annoncé que
due à la crise on a annulé le sommet qui
testera un sommet complètement
reconfiguré porté par stéphanie rivoal
qui elle même a une personnalité
nouvelle dans le dispositif qui adorent
c'est dès qu'elle a quittée et
qui visait justement à regrouper non
seulement les chefs d'état mais la
société civile les entrepreneurs les
collectivités locales c'est vraiment une
approche complètement nouvelle car mener
toutes les composantes en fait de la
société et du continent qui sont les
forces en fait qui font bouger le
développement et les vraies actions en
fait sur le terrain est donc pas rester
juste en chef d'état mais ce chat mixer
et a laissé la nouvelle approche en fait
qu'on voit nécessaire aujourd'hui pour
affronter les vrais problèmes
on peut pas
initialement les sommets un sommet par
définition d'ailleurs diplomatiquement
c'est des chefs d'état donc c'est
peut-être quimby ce qui crée la
confusion puisque personne ne comprend
plus trop ça reste dans la en fait dans
l'énergie à dire première d'un sommet
qui avait été revisité validée par le
président malheureusement annulé toute
façon ce sommet afrique france il va se
dérouler à montpellier en l'absence
quand même des chefs d'état c'est une
première esquisse vous le trouvez quand
même ambitieux emmanuel macron de les
avoir écartés de ce sommet encore une
fois je penche sur la question et sur la
terminologie en parlant de forme on
parle d'un sommet donc je pense qu'on
est resté encore une terminologie de
celle qui était appliqué au début et
effectivement quand les chefs d'état
donc ça fait bizarre ceux qui sont plus
habitués à cette logique du maintien
c'est quoi ce sommet sans chefs d'état
effectivement plus apparemment il n'en a
pas du tout donc c'est vraiment une
nouveauté en même temps si certains
viennent pourquoi pas les autres sacré
toute une discussion donc il ya eu pas
rentrer dedans c'est une vraie question
il ya maintenant maintenant ce qui est
clair c'est que le président il ya
toujours un fichier cette volonté et
c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs sa première
intervention était fameux discours de
ouaga devant les étudiants il a toujours
voulu créer cette connexion directe
entre lui et le terrain avec les
différents acteurs je pense à c'était la
nouveauté de son mandat ce qui aurait
été jusqu'au bout c'était justement de
faire ce sommet dans son format original
avec les chefs d'état africains avec les
différentes composantes entrepreneurs à
mais pas que les grosses entreprises à
acheter si chez pendant ce nouveau
format avec la société civile la
jeunesse l'opposition maman une des
raisons pour lesquelles les chefs d'état
font un peu l'impasse sur ce sommet
aussi qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ce
nouveau format ce que c'est une bonne
idée
du monde de l'innovation et l'innovation
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'open innovation donc c'est une
innovation qui implique toutes les
parties c'est comme ça qu'est née des
acteurs si fort que google hot on voit
des plateformes c'est justement
réunissent des acteurs différents 1 les
défis auxquels il est confronté
aujourd'hui appelleront à toutes les
composantes de la société de s'y
impliquer on peut plus juste racheté à
un niveau politique a discuté d'ailleurs
si on regarde même les formats des
nations génie ont changé aujourd'hui
implique la société civile les
entreprises privées etc le problème
c'est justement d'arriver à descendre en
profondeur et pas juste de rester sur
les grandes entreprises de 4,40 elle est
allée grunge est arrivé à descendre
vraiment sur le terrain ce qu'ils sont
on n'arrive pas à voir qu'ils sont
peut-être en train de faire des choses
extraordinaires mais qui sont hors du
corps du viseur et passionnera d'un et
c'était c'était l'ambition
maintenant ça se fait moi donc je pense
que le président a tenu à ce que ça se
fasse parce qu'il est resté dans sa
logique première d'avoir cet échange
direct et je pense que pour l'avoir
côtoyé c'est clair que sans leur mission
a toujours été d'avoir un contact direct
on voit même sort en politique locale
des qui peut il va quitte à se prendre
des baffes fois au contact du flic et
pourrait changer il aime avoir cet
échange est pas resté je savoir enfermé
dans une bulle je crois que tout le
danger et il en est très conscient c'est
de rester dans une bulle parce que après
c'est l'état profond c'est d'autres qui
vont engager les actions et qui vont des
formes est ce que vous faites vous allez
faire l'impasse sur le le sommet de
montpellier j'y serai pas square en fait
déjà jeu
je vais fait un peu le tour on va dire
des certaine manière donc j'ai pas je
pense pas y avoir quelque chose et là je
suis engagé sur des projets ou la lady
les airois
talents africains sur lequel je suis
engagé qui est un projet assez ambitieux
avec à l'échelle mondiale mais qu'on est
en train de transcrire au niveau
africain au pour justement identifié et
a lancé la première problématique
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir des talents
dans le digital pour pouvoir accompagner
la transformation
vous avez vous avez d'ailleurs dirigé
l'initiative portée par emmanuel macron
à digital africa d'une plateforme en
fait pour promouvoir l'entrepreneuriat
digital en afrique bon c'était une
expérience malheureuse pour vous je
crois que vous avez quittez vos
fonctions justement vous n'allez pas à
montpellier vous avez ou si vous étiez
vous êtes aussi un ex membre du conseil
présidentiel affrété un scan pointe
d'amertume quand même vis-à-vis des
initiatives ont été menées par emmanuel
macron aucune je pense qu'on a été en
rive pas naïfs c'est avec va changer
soixante ans d'histoire en deux jours on
irrité par contre avec la passion et la
conviction donc on s'est engagé
pleinement je pense le président a donné
cette capacité est cette envie on s'y
attendait pas mais je vous avoue qu'au
départ quand on m'a contacté pour
participer au conseil présidentiel je me
disais bon j'ai participé à des conseils
présidentielle en afrique où je suis
libre en rencontre une ou deux fois dans
l'année avec le président on discute
enfin un déjeuner un cocktail et puis on
s'en va c'est bon on a fait quelques
recommandations et puis ça se passe tant
mieux 1 et en fait dès le départ j'ai
été assez surpris bon déjà du gap qui
avait sali ça a été annoncé au à la
conférence de l'ambassade à la
conférence des ambassadeurs vous aviez
que des vieux ambassadeur caucasiens
très peu de femmes très peu de gens
issus de la diversité donc on voit bien
la problématique locale président a
voulu se confronter et donc sur
l'afrique un gros sujet de dire j'ai
même dit joël ou en tout cas dix
personnes ont strictement rien à voir
avec les cursus classique et les jeter
je vais vous dire quand vous et h dans
le conseil dans cette rencontre
et voir l'enthousiasmé en fait
qu'afficher le président dès le début
j'ai été assez surpris et il faut dire
qu'il a joué le jeu parce que tous les 3
mois vous voyez et quand on sait la
journée d'un président français à voir
plus d'une heure président
en face à face et pouvoir échanger avec
lui bannir complètement
ouverte et ça c'était assez fort de voir
qu'en fait il parlait vraiment
été c'est bien je mens force et un
virage présidentielle en matière de
politique africaine se met dans bouche
on va le voir avec digital africa une
belle et grande ambition pour promouvoir
l'entrepreneuriat numérique en afrique
mais l'association a très vite plongé
dans la tourmente d'ailleurs je le dis
vous avez un peu jeté l'épongé karim si
on va en parler les détails c'est avec
nadège à berlin
réinventer les relations entre l'afrique
et la france en soutenant les talents
numérique à concrétiser leurs ambitions
c'était l'objectif de digital afrique a
une ambition un peu trop grande sans
doute elle l'idée de départ est
intéressante et soutenu par dix
organisations issues des deux côtés de
la méditerranée
il s'agissait de réunir une communauté
de partenaires au service des
entreprises numériques africaines
pourrait parvenir emmanuel macron
annonçait en 2018 une dotation de 65
millions d'euros or ce programme
j'appelle tous les entrepreneurs
africains de tous les pays du continent
à se joindre à cette initiative des
tutelles africains et joindre la
plateforme depuis six mois un travail
important a été fait avec l' agence
française de développement que je
remercie et l'afd va déployer dans les
prochaines semaines un instrument
spécifique
doté de 65 millions d'euros pour lancer
l'initiative mais qui va être destiné à
combler cette faille de l'accompagnement
par des petits tickets mais qui sont
ceux dans ces startups ont besoin de
trente à cinquante mille euros
la première phase et qui va accompagner
les projets qui seront sélectionnés sur
la plateforme digitale africa rapidement
l'application revendique une communauté
de 6000 entrepreneurs locaux mais des
divergences apparaissent au sein de la
gouvernance le président du conseil
karim s'ils démissionnent en juin 2020
son remplaçant par intérim le nigérian
kizito ok choukoud jette lui aussi
l'épongé
moins d'un an plus tard l'afrique sans
les africains antoine glaser l'a écrit
l'afd l'a fait avec digital africa
comment une initiative présidentielle
tombent dans le piège africain
françafrique quand tu nous tiens le
président macron l'a dit dans son
intervention les membres africains
critique des choix qui valorise la mise
en réseau plus que les programmes eux
mêmes le rôle du principal financeur l'
agence française de développement est
très critiqué pour résumer la vie des
est accusée de dicter aux africains
membres du conseil d'administration
ce qu'ils doivent faire le conseil a été
constamment contourner et rarement
informés obtenant la plupart de ces
informations par le biais d'annoncés sur
les réseaux sociaux les voix des trois
membres africains du conseil
d'administration qui ensemble
représentent une communauté de plus d'un
million d'entrepreneurs africains sont
ignorés complications sur complications
digital africa est devenu une patate
chaude pour l'exécutif l'initiative
frôlé la dissolution alors que beaucoup
croient le projet enterré une période
transitoire de trois à cinq mois destiné
à reformer l'association est décidé
certains ne mâchent pas leurs mots
estiment que ce projet est en réalité
une continuité de la françafrique de
l'optimisme à la déception africa
digital a surtout fait ressurgir à des
rancoeurs du passé et il n'est pas sûr
qu'une simple refonte de l'association
suffisent à effacer ce sentiment on va
marquer une courte pause et se retrouver
dans un instant dans afrique connect
reste avec nous sur rt france
retour dans afrique honnête sur rt
france consacré au sommet afrique france
de montpellier et aux initiatives franco
africaine nous en parlons avec notre
invité karim six fondateurs du chocolat
ex-membre du conseil présidentiel
africain ex-dirigeant de digital
africains ont évoqué au digital africa
on évoquait justement les problèmes de
gouvernance au sein de cette plateforme
initié par emmanuel macron au départ sur
la composition de la gouvernance vous
êtes trois africains et neuf français il
ya un déséquilibre d'emblée est ce que
c'est un problème pour vous ça c'est pas
un problème parce que déjà je vais le
soutien plein du président et ça c'est
extrêmement important et en fait sans ça
on n'aurait rien fait les partenaires
français étaient aussi identifié pour
couvrir tout le territoire et souvent
parle
la france mais ça se résume à paris aux
acteurs parisiens a quelques-uns qui est
qui en fait monopoliste où le débat sur
l'afrique sans forcément d'ailleurs
souvent la connaître et ça c'est pénible
et donc on a vraiment pris le soin
d'aller chercher des acteurs de terrain
qui couvre la france qu'on fait des
actions sur l'afrique et donc qu'ils ont
acquis sont reconnus aussi sur le
terrain ou qui veulent y aller des
acteurs comme à la ferme digital c'est
tout le monde a great wall c'est la
technologie du monde agricole cela qu'on
a participé au salon de l'agriculture
c'était la première fois que vous voyez
les africains au salon de l'agriculture
c'est quand même un truc qui est
extraordinaire c'est l'innovation et
saint-louis ses innovations et en plus
dans des sujets on les attendait pas
c'était quelque chose d'extraordinaire
et aujourd'hui c'est devenu une habitude
donc voilà c'est là qu'on change la
vraie relation digital afrique a été
doté par emmanuel macron d'une enveloppe
de 65 millions d'euros je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ça peu à peu près 130
millions d'euros est ce que c'est une
initiative qui se poursuit avec rebecca
une eau chaude fondatrice d'apt
dénonciez une sorte de diktat de
l'agencé française de développement
l'afd qu'il grand argentier finalement
de cette initiative des jt à l'africa
vous n'avez rien vu venir vraiment rêver
qu'un qui représente 1 fry lab qui avait
quand même eu un réseau de tout l'été
cup et à plus de 700 aujourd'hui en
afrique qui couvre tout le continent de
l'egypte en passant par l'afrique du sud
il dote donc pas juste les compos dans
l'eau claire on était vraiment dans la
logique du tout afrique c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'important ça les trois
ont représenté quand même pas n'importe
quoi je pense l'afd bon c'est normal
c'est le
hampate ba disait la main qui donne est
au dessus de celle qui reçoit donc on en
est conscient par contre on avait un
gentleman agreement
quelque part de se dire on est ensemble
pour construire le futur ceux d'entre
eux la gueulante à sauter encore une
fois quand la directrice est venu
française bon c'est vrai que je n'ai pas
fait attention à son profit le quai
d'orsay et c'est donc finalement très
sortie du moule
souvent on va retrouver
la france a du mal à déléguer à des
acteurs des etats unis rod on va voir
des acteurs de la société civile haute
portée des projets sur ce qu'on pense
qu'on n'est pas habitué mal à l'aise
changement de culture votre culture qu'a
voulu le président mais qui est loin
d'avoir ruisseler encore au niveau des
organisations donc là on se retrouve
face à un problème alors fait pour moi
c'est ça fait ressortir complètement les
questions de l'état profond on a eu des
cas où je me retrouve en réunion
publique où vous avez des gens de
l'administration française qui m'a dit
écoutez dans trois ans le président il
sera peut-être pas là donc en gros j'ai
pas envie de le faire donc je ne ferai
pas donc on a une défiance qu'elle a
aussi dans l'administration et donc donc
c'est beaucoup plus profond que ça après
on a aussi des enjeux de compréhension
des vues vous avez passé un extrait où
le président parle d'une plateforme on
parle d'une plateforme numérique on est
au 21ème siècle et on parle vie digitale
et mais il m'est arrivé à la fin dans
les notes on était obligé de préciser
plateforme numérique parce que certains
de nos interlocuteurs on sait que c'est
une plateforme d'échangé physique où je
sais par d'autres comme un forum attend
donc donc c'est dire aussi le gap qui se
posent vous êtes vous accordez vous dans
le piège de digital africain emmanuel
macron lui dans le piège africain dixit
pascal airault et antoine glaser
coauteur du piège africains de macron du
continent à l'hexagone on écoute il ya
une détestation des chefs d'états de des
pays francophones de ce qu'elle est pré
pré carré il ne maîtrise pas et il est
fou furieux de voir que finalement il ya
des pesanteurs il s'aperçoit mais le
jeune macron qu'il suffit pas comme on a
tous eu notre jeunesse de prendre leur
d'oise magique comme ça le tir et la
glace magique sur 30 ans comme le dit
pascal de coopération de françafrique
est un système intégré politique
militaire financier de 60 jusqu'à la
chute du mur de berlin et donc qui tient
la route mavic il dit ben voila moi je
je renverse il est discret il aime bien
descriptif je renverse la faire dès
maintenant chômage aux sociétés civiles
africaines en même temps c'est l'écho
des savanes inversée je m'adresse pas à
la france en afrique mais à l'afrique en
france donc c'est j'inverse le truc je
change la donne de tous les côtés et en
plus je me l'offrir l'europe au premier
trimestre 2001 ne est passé de la
françafrique politique à une
françafrique intellectuel et culturel
avec ce sommet on est en plein on est en
plein dedans il ya chez macron l'idée
d'aller coopter des personnalités
marquantes médiatique qui puisse servir
d'exemple après pour
enclencher un mouvement a tiré un
certain nombre il veut briser des noeuds
mémorielle aussi et il a une obsession
qui est de changer le regard des
africains sur la france est également le
regard des français sur l'afrique c'est
sa grande déception donc pour ça il lui
faut des personnalités des gens qui sont
capables de parler devant une scène dans
un théâtre dans une grande arène là
comme à montpellier ce week-end qu'ils
puissent avoir un discours qui est de la
contenu et qu'ils puissent encore amener
du rêve aussi un côté un peu tapis je ne
sais pas c'est le moment d'en parler au
niveau des eaux usées mais il ya ce rêve
là que le président français c'est de
vendre aussi
mais ce qu'on comprend dans le piège
africain justement de macron à pascal
airault et et d'antoine glaser c'est que
finalement le conseil présidentiel
africains leur groupe les premiers de
cordée de la diaspora on comprend que
c'est une initiative élitiste bazas et
inclusive au détriment finalement de la
diaspora d'en bas celle des banlieues
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je fais un
corps parce que vous aviez j'avais lys
gomis et d'autres acteurs gens qui
connaissent
qui sont en contact avec la banlieue
comme on le dit et puis on n'est pas
dans notre bulle on était sur le terrain
et justement quand ce que je disait
régulièrement c'est que il s'agit pas
d'être dans les réseaux classiques seat
bons les uns déjà donc c'est ça
l'intérêt est d'ailleurs pour ça je
pense que les outils digitaux encore une
fois effet extrêmement important et je
pense qu'on les a pas assez déployés
pour consulter de manière large succès
de l'afrique ces 54 pays c'est le
première rencontre ils n'ont pas ce que
vous regardez bien ce n'est pas
l'afrique vont frôler finalement
justement vous parlez de ça et mais non
mais c'est les deux c'est moi je suis
franco africain j'ai grandi entre la
france et l'afrique
donc j'ai ouvert la première fois qu' on
a eu cette rencontre avec le président
on appelle j'ai parlé pendant que les
problèmes des certificats de nationalité
j'ai perdu mon certificat de nationalité
la force de déménager de voyages etc et
je me suis rendu compte derrière de
sarkozy je pouvais pas renouveler mon
passeport j'avais une carte d'identité
je pouvais voter je peux pas renouveler
mon passeport je n'ai pas de certificat
sanitaire me dit non ça c'est pas un
sujet présidentielle même si j'en ai
parlé au président qu'elle a noté parce
que c'est un vrai sujet pour les
diasporas oui les personnes issues de la
diversité ou comment vous les appelez en
france parce que tout d'un coup on
devient un
citoyen qui est pendu à un papier au
canada on vous le renouvelle en ligne là
il faut refaire tout le processus de
demande de la société vous imaginez et
moi j'étais un cas facile
né en france etc et j'avais les papiers
de mes grands parents
et mon père on en est quand même un truc
donc vous imaginez le parcours du
combattant donc donc ça on voit bien et
le président d'adidas a été entendu il
ya une part d'afrique en france ssh toi
donc le problème aussi et c'est là qu'on
tombe dans le piège et africains c'est
qu'en fait on est dans un éternel à
l'air autour en une politique nationale
ce qu'en fait si on maltraite les sud
africains en france entre guillemets ou
les français d'origine africaine parce
qu'en fait ils sont français on est
français il
ya eu africa france par exemple qui
regroupait aussi la diaspora l'idée
aussi ces deux d'entre de promouvoir
aussi
l'entrepreneuriat africains de faciliter
le réseau entre les entreprises
françaises et africaines bon ça a été
initiée par françois hollande dirigé par
lionel zinsou africa france n'existe
plus dit j'étais à l'africa on a compris
que c'était là la tourmente et le cpa
finalement ces instances de noël et des
initiatives utiles ou c'est de la pure
communication
je pense un tournant de génération au
vert il y aille à pourvoir et la france
a compris quand même qu'aujourd'hui il
faut repenser les relations
ça il faut pas être einstein pour le
comprendre jean souvent l'a compris non
c'est le comment alors première
initiative effectivement un flic de
france le revoir en irlande là on est
dans la france issu du ministère des
affaires étrangères 3 millions d'euros
de budget vient sous grands technocrates
français que c'est un des indes et
des binationaux qui s'est le plus
illustré en france si on n'a pas
beaucoup en fait on va regarder et c'est
ça aussi le problème quels sont les
champions et référence alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir aussi c'est
que on a de plus en plus alors pour
parler de la sd la vidéo vous avez dit
que des français aujourd'hui vous avez
des africains qui sont recrutés
quelqu'un très nouveau à et vous avez
l'air le nouveau directeur afrique et
christan
qui d'origine camerounaise donc on
commence
internationaux s'il est dépourvue
d'internet même des comme phil mills a
annoncé que de l'absence d'emmanuel
mâcon pour les pays anglophones en
afrique parce qu'on sait que l'un de ses
premiers voyages c'était le nigeria ces
54 pays encore une fois mais est-ce que
c'est pas risqué pour lui quand même de
de composer avec des esprits
indépendants
d'autres comme celui d'achille mbembe là
où c'est le respect c'est ce que oui
cergy démissionner moi je suis et puis
je suis retourné faire mes affaires je
basée à dakar moi j'étais à paris dieu
merci des revers chez la capacité de
porter digital africains
parce que souvent je croise des gens et
d'un maintien n'était pas à paris
j'étais à paris pour les besoins digital
5 1 je rappelle que président d'une
association c'est volontaire j'avais un
engagement moi j'ai grandi dans cette
lotion du lien je suis issue même de ce
lien avec des parents et de mère
libanaise un père malien d'origine
sénégalaise donc forcément c'est dans
mon adn est donc ce projet ray
extrêmement intéressant il faut lui
donner sa chance et on dit le club du
changement c'est pas de de lutter contre
le passé mais c'est de mettre toutes ses
énergies dans la construction du futur
et moi c'est ce à quoi je m'appelle
croyez aux relations mais je crois
complètement ses impasses fernando
jenson qui revient souvent que oui mais
parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas assez de
il faut que ça descende mais faut que ça
ruisselle ça peut pas être juste le
président qui fait une incantation et
après ça s'apprend pas il faut que ça
arrive à descendre mais au plus profond
la france c'est ça le sujet et donc on
voit de plus en plus de gens ici de la
diversité qu'ils puissent s'exprimer
aussi et que du coup l'heure l'heure
leurs mondiaux et même en français j'ai
fait la visite du président à l'île de
la réunion vous savez les dom-tom on
voit se sont pas on nous parle
l'hexagone est une espèce de rupture qui
ce fait et on le fait même sur les
campagnes en france et même sur les
jours donc je dis encore c'est réparé
trek paul bertin le colbertisme c'est
donc il faut aujourd'hui que la france
se retrouve à sa diversité qui est
française la guyane et c'est un héros et
donc dès ce moment là qu en se
nourrissant de ses divers à 20 pouvoir
mieux parler à au monde au monde en
général d'air parce que la france en
fait est présente dans tous les maux
merci beaucoup qui arrive et si l'on
vous reviendrez nous parler de la
transformation digitale en actionnaires
grand plaisir retrouvé à free connecte
sur nos réseaux sociaux et en replay sur
notre site rt france point tv merci aux
équipes du mag était aux équipes
techniques pour la préparation de cette
émission merci de votre attention à très
bientôt dans afrique honnête sur arte
france